Oh yeah, give me that.
I got this one right here.
Oh God.
Mine are gonna be so...
What is Jake Gyllenhaal...
This could just end right there.
What is Jake Gyllenhaal?
Is Jake Gyllenhaal...
Do you know what it is?
Your zodiac sign?
Yeah.
Yeah, you're a Capricorn.
What was Jake Gyllenhaal's first movie?
October Sky.
Nope.
It was a big movie.
No.
What was it?
"A Dangerous Woman" maybe, I think it was called.
Your parents let you be in a movie called "A Dangerous Woman"?
Yeah I was...
At what age?
I was like 11 or something like that, 10 or something.
What does Jake Gyllenhaal...
What does he eat?
Well, funny you should ask, baby pandas.
What does Jake Gyllenhaal tattoo say?
I don't have tattoos, man.
What time was Jake Gyllenhaal born?
I think I was born early in the morning.
I'm pretty sure.